former acting homeland security
secretary heritage foundation visiting
fellow chad wolfe chad i mean we
continue to hear these numbers and these
stories over and over again and here's
the thing they continue to amaze they
continue to be mind-boggling that you
would let someone go and say by the way
come back later and show up for a
hearing i'm almost shocked that half did
to be quite frank with you
at these this ntr program apparently
they're not it's been discontinued but
who thought this would work in the first
place well it's essentially the honor
system right they're asking migrants to
show up at a local ice office uh but
there's no way to actually track that so
there's no way to know where they are
and look the reason why they did it if
you recall back uh in march april may
and june is because they were
overwhelmed at the border because they
had throughout the campaign and
throughout all their policies since they
took over they have been encouraging
migrants to come to the border to claim
asylum knowing that the majority of
those are false claims and so it's no
surprise that they got overwhelmed and
by getting overwhelmed they couldn't do
the proper paperwork uh to issue notice
to appears instead notices to report and
again it's essentially the honor system
uh so to have 50 000 again that's just
through august i think we need to keep
in mind the haitians that we saw in del
rio that was in september i i can
guarantee you the majority of those were
also issued notice to reports as well so
that number 50 47 48 000 is probably
much higher
as you as you go all the way through the
end of 2021. you know we're talking
about the messaging through the uh
during the election which was
essentially hey uh you know come on up
you know red carpet green light come on
up we've got vacancies
since in in recent weeks we've got new
york city
on the verge of allowing hundreds of
thousands of undocumented
migrants vote and now the governor in
california are promising economic
benefits as well
how how do you stem how do you ever
control your border uh any country any
nation in the world uh when once you get
through you know that you the honor
system you'll never have to report back
you'll be able to vote you'll also have
economic gains i mean really it's it's
you know i'm asking because you know
we've got a lot of citizens in this
country who we're the greatest country
in the world we've got the kindest
hearts in the world we're the most
generous we've lost blood we've lost
treasures we spent trillions to help
everyone around the planet but shouldn't
we
do it be smarter with respect to an
organized way of allowing folks into
this nation this seems like they're
going to create a free-for-all
well it is creating a free fall and i
think that's why you see the worst
border crisis that we have seen ever
certainly in our lifetimes but really
ever and i think
the united states continues to be one of
the most generous and welcoming
countries around the world but there is
a legal way there is an orderly way and
there's process to get into the country
legally
but when you discard that and when
you're the bite administration and you
put forth a set of policies and
messaging that encourage illegal
behavior to come across you end up with
what you have today which is a complete
a colossal failure of a border security
and immigration enforcement strategy
and i think that's what's leading i
think a lot of people are scratching
their heads and saying what is going on
it's not only the migrants but it's
national security threats that are
coming to that border as well yeah i
mean people from every single country in
the world chad wolfe thank you very much
hey sean hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to fox news youtube page and
catch our hottest interviews and most
compelling analysis you will not get it
anywhere else